[Música]
vivimos en un mundo rodeado de
tecnología cada día usamos celulares
internet bluetooth y muchos otros
aparatos sin detenernos a pensar en cómo
funcionan o quién los desarrolló la
tecnología está en constante evolución
cada año se inventan nuevas cosas o se
desarrollan las que ya conocemos para
hacerlas más eficientes y accesibles
para todos por ejemplo una pulsera que
proyecta en tu brazo las aplicaciones de
tu smartphone o la realidad virtual que
no solo se usa como un complemento del
videojuego sino también para fines
educativos como estudiantes de medicina
realizando operaciones quirúrgicas
utilizando la realidad virtual o coches
autónomos que como su nombre lo dice no
necesitan ser conducidos por una persona
así el usuario puede hacer otras
actividades y aunque parece que el
factor más importante aquí es la
comodidad no lo es es la seguridad ya
que muchos de los accidentes son
provocados por errores o distracciones
de los humanos y qué tal que en un
futuro estos coches pudieran ser usados
por personas con discapacidad así
podrían desplazarse y tendrían una vida
más independiente en este aspecto
y qué tal si hablamos en el área médica
en donde hay un sinfín de avances
tecnológicos que en un futuro próximo
serán una realidad se hablan implantes
de microchips en el cerebro para
recobrar funciones de implantes de
corazón
usando corazones de otros animales de
nanobots introducidos al cuerpo para
detectar el cáncer y segregar en esa
zona un agente para eliminar las células
malignas y algo que suena muy
impresionante y alentador es la
impresión tridimensional de órganos o
partes del cuerpo en donde científicos e
ingenieros médicos usando impresoras
tridimensionales y computadoras
produzcan órganos artificiales para
trasplantes definitivos o temporales
imagínense lo que será que las personas
que necesiten órganos no tengan que
estar en esas largas listas de espera no
les suena todo esto como a ciencia
ficción definitivamente si estos avances
continúan se revolucionará la manera en
que detectamos y curamos enfermedades y
problemas médicos
de los adelantos en exploración espacial
saben la cantidad de experimentos que se
hacen en la estación internacional
espacial muchos de ellos están
relacionados con el desarrollo de
plantas y animales o de biotecnología
cimentados en condiciones de
microgravedad pero bueno no de estos
sorprende mucho a los de mi generación
ya que dicen que nosotros nacimos con la
tecnología integrada y es verdad cuando
yo nací en mi casa ya había internet
pantallas planas que existían los
celulares las computadoras el gps y
muchas otras cosas y hay veces que
nosotros sabemos más de tecnología y de
aplicaciones que los adultos en
repetidas ocasiones nuestros padres nos
piden ayuda para usar sus smartphones
nos recuerdan muchos de ustedes los
simpáticos que se veían nuestros papás
cuando deslizaban la pantalla de su
celular con un dedo y bruscamente
pero también les digo que me es
increíble pensar que mis papás crecieron
sin mucha de esta tecnología o no
vayamos lejos sin una computadora aunque
les debo de confesar que la primera vez
que yo vi a una máquina de escribir
quedé maravillada con ese artefacto y me
lo quería llevar aún cuando yo tenía una
computadora en casa definitivamente la
tecnología siempre ha estado en mi vida
pero desafortunadamente desde que tengo
memoria también he oído hablar como una
constante del cambio climático del
calentamiento global de la contaminación
de la escasez de agua y de alimentos de
animales en peligro de extinción y vaya
hasta el fin del mundo como es posible
que si somos tan creativos logrando un
impresionante desarrollo solucionando
problemas una y otra vez y desarrollando
toda esta tecnología no hayamos podido
remediar estas situaciones que en
ustedes que podríamos cambiar y mejorar
el mundo una vez más afortunadamente ya
existe un plan pero sólo puede funcionar
si todos trabajamos juntos en el 2015 la
organización de las naciones unidas que
representa a la población de 193 países
anunció los 17 objetivos mundiales del
desarrollo sostenible
enfocados en las personas el planeta la
paz la prosperidad y las alianzas a fin
de alcanzar tres propósitos erradicar la
pobreza extrema luchar contra la
desigualdad y la injusticia y luchar
contra el cambio climático
en otras palabras proteger el planeta y
lograr que este mundo sea un lugar más
seguro más justo y más equitativo
tenemos que alcanzar estos objetivos
para el 2030 y como es un plan se puede
comprobar si lo estamos cumpliendo no
falta mucho para el 2030 necesitamos
apoyarnos los unos a los otros
usar nuestra imaginación y creatividad
pero sobre todo comprometernos con el
cambio si damos a conocer estos
objetivos de manera masiva otras
personas podrán interesarse y así
cooperar ese es mi propósito con esta
charla
los 17 objetivos del desarrollo
sostenible son 1 fin de la pobreza 2
hambre 03 salud y bienestar 4 educación
de calidad 5 igualdad de género 6 agua
limpia y saneamiento 7 energías y kylie
no contaminante 8 trabajo decente y
crecimiento económico 9 industria
innovación e infraestructura 10
reducción de las desigualdades 11
ciudades y comunidades sostenibles 12
producción y consumo responsables 13
acciones por el clima 14 vida submarina
15 vida de ecosistemas terrestres 16 paz
justicia e instituciones sólidas y 17
alianzas para lograr los objetivos
después viene la parte más emocionante
que es pensar cada uno de nosotros qué
podemos hacer para aportar nuestro
granito de arena una manera de proteger
el planeta sería no desperdiciar el agua
los alimentos y la electricidad si
dependiéramos a las personas que son
tratadas injustamente también
marcaríamos una gran diferencia así como
respetando los derechos humanos como son
17 objetivos tenemos posibilidad de
contribuir de muchas formas con nuevas
pero sobre todo nuevas maneras de hacer
las cosas nuevas maneras de disponer de
agua limpia y potable o reciclar toda la
basura y nuevas soluciones en contra de
la inequidad de género afortunadamente
ya se realizan acciones en muchas partes
del mundo para lograr los objetivos pero
aún no es suficiente en cuanto a
acciones por el clima vida submarina y
vida de ecosistemas terrestres existe
por ejemplo en la campaña nuestro o no
uses popote que evita la contaminación y
protege la vida marina hay
organizaciones que están limpiando los
mares de basura y plástico también hay
campañas que promueven el reciclaje
entre muchas otras
yo lo personal me he preocupado en el
medio por el medio ambiente he
participado en campañas de limpieza de
reforestación en mi ciudad y hace poco
participe junto con unos compañeros de
mi salón en una feria de ciencias dentro
del colegio en donde nuestra consigna
era crear un producto que ayudara al
medio ambiente a mejorar uno ya
existente con la misma finalidad al
principio no teníamos una clara idea de
qué hacer pero después se nos ocurrió
hacer unos lápices reciclando periódicos
pero la idea no nos convenció del todo
porque ya se fabrican y no sabíamos qué
mejorar es a partir de esta opción se
nos ocurrió ser una masa utilizando
hojas secas de árbol molidas que
mezclamos con los residuos de pegamento
que nos sobró de los lápices de
periódico y con esto enrollamos puntas
de lápices y grafitos después dejamos
que se secarán para probarlos y el
resultado nos sorprendió luego nos dimos
a la tarea de buscar un producto que
sustituyera el pegamento así no
estaríamos utilizando químicos y
experimentamos que la grenetina puede
cumplir con el mismo propósito y es de
origen animal
presentamos este producto en la feria de
ciencias porque creemos que puede ayudar
a evitar la tala de árboles que se
cortan para producir madera para hacer
lápices y esto hizo que ganáramos el
primer lugar
como pueden ver todos podemos contribuir
y proponer sólo nos quedan 12 años antes
del 2030 y hay mucho por hacer los
invito a tomar acciones participar y
aportar para que juntos y unidos
logremos los 17 objetivos mundiales del
desarrollo sostenible manejamos un
modelo de vida que tristemente no
respeta los límites biofísicos del
planeta pero ahora ya sabemos que
tenemos que poner la protección en el
centro vivimos en la tierra y dependemos
de ella para vivir aunque no todos
compartimos la misma cultura todos
compartimos el mismo planeta y todo lo
que necesitamos está justo aquí siempre
y cuando lo cuidemos tenemos un
compromiso con el planeta y con las
personas que lo compartimos y lo
compartiremos si seguramente algún día
encontraremos vida inteligente en otro
lugar obtendremos la capacidad de crear
el ambiente necesario en otro lugar pero
mientras tanto les propongo que usemos
nuestra inteligencia y salvar al planeta
que llamamos hogar tal vez muchos de
ustedes dirán suena interesante o mira
qué bonito pero lo que realmente
necesito es que en este momento tu
cabeza ya está ideando y aprobando tu
aportación para lograr los objetivos del
desarrollo sostenible
y es lo que vas a hacer tu manos a la
obra gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]